if you have a YouTube channel and you're
already doing all of the basic things
but you're not getting the results that
you want in this video I'm going to go
over the five of the higher level
strategies that entrepreneurs are using
on YouTube to win for each of the five
strategies I'm going to look at a
Channel of someone in my mover makers
program these are thought leaders who
are already posting weekly videos
creating thumbnails hooking Their
audience in the first minute and have
all of the basics down and now they want
to take it to the next level to grow
their audiences and grow their
businesses let's dive in together and
hey if you want to join us in makers 2
check the link in the description
below okay the first strategy is to go
longer with your YouTube videos and
we're going to use Dan Thompson as our
example here so Dan Thompson Financial
expert speaker author investor business
owner you know he's got his profile His
Banner his Avatar he's got all his
videos set up amazing the thing that Dan
is missing the most is going longer with
the content so you look at his videos 5
and a half minutes 4 minutes 8 minutes
25 minutes this is good 17 minutes
that's getting better seven minutes
where it's really really really hard to
rank a 4minute video you got to be doing
some pretty epic content nowadays feel
the rank and you need to understand that
people are going to YouTube to learn so
one of the biggest differences between a
YouTube uh and an Instagram Facebook
other platforms is that the other
platforms that are short formed they're
going for inspiration so you go to
Instagram to get inspiration you're
going to YouTube to learn and so if I
want to learn how to invest my money I
want to learn from Dan Thompson the
expert here how am I going to do it I'm
going to go to YouTube I'm going to type
in different keywords and different
videos are going to pop up and if you
hook me for the first minute so people
say well they have a really short
attention span that's true people have a
short attention span in the first minute
if you can hook them for the first
minute our ideal goal is 70% at 1 minute
if you can hit people at 70% retention
at one minute they will stick and
continue to watch the rest of the video
and so the key is to get them in the
first minute for that short attention
span but then go longer so the advice
that I always get people is 10- minute
minimum but if you have more to say keep
going right this one here is says part
two if you have a part one and part two
combine them together don't do part one
part two smush them together this video
with part one and part two if this was
you know a 40 minute video it would do
better than both of these combined and
so be willing to go long if you have
something great to say if you are an
expert do not be afraid to go long we're
seeing the biggest growth in the 1 to
three hour category the people will not
watch a one to three hour video they
will because you're teaching them if you
actually have something to say you have
a deep well of knowledge do not be
afraid to go along with the content so
10 minute minimum uh Dan and everybody
else and one to three hours is a huge
growth category if you can go that long
and an easy thing to think about how to
go through it is you're earning an
expert think about all the questions
that people ask you all the problems
that that come to you on a daily basis
and give me your advice tell me your
story so with every with every video you
have a problem that we're trying to set
up right here's the number one problem
then we're going to have a story that
you tell your story client story story
in the news and then you give me advice
and if you're giving me three bits of
advice for every video if you think
about it usually my formula goes
powerful opinion context sentence race a
stake story and then give me your advice
and so the advice is one two three bits
of advice so if you're doing all of that
that's at least a 20- minute video
already and so you just need to have the
right formula to be able to make the
content and people will watch people
will watch people will love this they're
learning a lot of information people are
going to YouTube to learn and so do not
be afraid to go longer with the content
and Dan I'm looking forward to seeing
more people seeing your content so when
I tell people this they say well what
about people like Alex Heros is off
making these short videos and he's
crushing it well let's look at Alex her
Moi you know let's go pull up his
channel and let's see what his best
videos are
here that we've got going on here so
Alex heroi almost at two million
subscribers at the time of this
recording amazing and if we go to his
videos and then we can look at his
latest ones and he has been going longer
right 17 minutes 52 minutes 24 minutes
24 minutes 2 so what you may have seen
at the early days of Alex OSI these
short videos you can see now that he's
really starting to go much longer with
his content and if you look at as the
most popular of all time you have this
one which was killer this was about AI
if you haven't seen n Go watch his video
this short one here is this epic rant
that he has on the plane in reaction to
somebody this is also definitely worth
to watch and then the only other short
one here is this one which is 7 minutes
long which is over a year ago but look
at the popular videos 51 minutes long
2.8 million views 53 minutes long 2.1
million views 56 minutes long one
million views and these are the newer
ones like three months old four months
old these will continue to grow this one
has been catching up on this one this is
soon going to be his number one video
right this one is still a 17-minute
video got 2.9 million views in 10 months
this is 3 months old 2.8 million views
so this 51 minute video is about the be
his best video and so when people look
at Alex and say well he's doing short
form content he's doing shorts which are
fine but he's also moving towards longer
form videos because they are performing
better so do not be afraid to go along
with your content if you have something
to say Alex would crush with a
three-hour video I would love to see it
challenge to Mr hosi let's see a
three-hour video and let's see if that
video doesn't go instantly and become
his number one video on his channel okay
strategy number two is want a consistent
thumbnail design so here I'm looking at
another movement maker Bo Xin he has
been crushing it with his show and
bringing in deals uh he just landed
another deal that was 30 or $40,000 as a
result of having a guest on his show so
something we teach inside the movie
makers program is to do a BISD show
think about the people that if they knew
who you are would lead to revenue for
you and then start a show and have them
come on so you build a relationship so
he's been crushing that generating tons
of money doing it but when I want to
talk about with his channel is a
consistent thumbnail design so if you
look at his videos you can see he's
consistent this man is pumping out
content two days ago uh three days ago
three days ago four days ago he also
suffers from being too short right so
the the content should be much longer
two minute video two minute video five
minute video it's gonna be really hard
to get these videos ranking uh but we've
already talked about that so the key
thing for him is consistent thumbnail
design so the thing he has going for him
is he is in every thumbnail a lot of
times it's that similar kind of LinkedIn
profile picture that you see everywhere
but what you want people to do is
instantly know that it's your thumbnail
so what does a bow thumbnail look like
so in His Banner he's using you know
this blue and he's got this kind of aqua
color and if that's your color and
that's your font make that consistent
because it's so much easier for people
to see the videos one of the main ways
to grow your channel is through
suggested if you look at the big
channels you look at someone look at
Alex and I was growing it's through
suggested right it's not through search
we think of YouTube as the world's
second largest search engine and it is
but most of the growth from the big
channels come from suggested inside of
education and thought leadership what
that means is when I load one of your
videos and I'm watching
this I want to see your video showing up
down the
side and this is where a lot of the
views will come and so every time you're
looking at one video then most people
even if they start with a search they
don't go back to the search results they
start going down the rabbit hole what
gets recommended to them and so this is
where you want to be showing up so the
challenge with a thumbnail design that's
all over the place even this one like
this one's done okay for Alex this is
not a great thumbnail for him because
you can't see Alex's face and so if I'm
skipping through this quickly I see Dave
Ramsey I don't necessarily instantly
recognize that that's Alex and so I
might pass it over even if I'm
subscribed to the channel even if I love
Alex and what he's all about because the
thumbnail design is way off and it's
hard to instantly know that that's him
compared to I know that this is Patrick
B David I know that this is Tony Robins
I know that this is Tom Bilu you know
even Gary Gary could do a better job do
I know instantly that that's Gary ve no
and if I'm seeing it on the phone it's
going to be even smaller so harder to
see so Gary needs to fix his thumbnails
Alex needs to fix his thumbnails they
would get more suggested views it's the
same problem that B has here if I watch
you know if I see this and I look at
this and that's B and I get this color
and font and layout and like I know that
this is what they're all about cool if I
see this video and I click on it and
then I'm watching it and then I see this
one show up down the side does that is
that B I don't know it looks like a
different guy and he's not in his suit
and it's a different font and it's a
different color scheme and so I might
watch this video and love it but then I
see this one down the side or I see this
one down the side or I see this one down
the side and because they all look
completely different I may not click on
the video so he was losing people who
want to click on his videos but they
don't instantly recognize him and so
that's what we want to do is we we want
to create a brand this is not anything
new to YouTube you want to have a brand
that is identifiable why do companies
spend so much on logos and fonts and
assets because it means something
because you want people to instantly
recognize you and so this is the huge
opportunity here for Bo I wouldn't worry
so much about these short videos and
fixing them because short videos like
this are basically dead so B obviously
needs to go longer but all of these
videos we need to figure out what is our
thumb nail design look at this one it's
it's black and white it's small I would
even if I know bow and I love all this
content and I see this down the side I'm
probably not going to click on it
because I don't know that that's Bose's
content so we need to figure out what is
a thumbnail uh design that's winning
what are our colors and our fonts that
represent our brand so that we can stand
out and then making that consistent
across all of our thumbnails so that we
will show up down the side and people
will click okay let's go to strategy
number three which is make it clear what
you do one of the biggest challenges
that a lot of entrepreneurs have when
you're creating content is like we know
what we do but does our audience know
what we do so here's another great
example Another Movie Maker Jill Collins
she has her Channel Jill Collins
connections again she's making content
four days ago 11 days ago two weeks ago
three weeks ago so she's staying in the
minimum of once a week that would be my
recommendation for everybody once a week
means you're in the game if you're
asking how many videos should I make at
least once a week that gets you in the
game so she is doing that plus a little
B more so that's great when I come to
the page so I don't really know what
she's about so Jill Collins okay she
looks successful she's got her logo she
looks like she's a somebody and she's
comfortable in front of the camera and
she's done some photo shoots great but I
don't know what connections plus means
I'm not sure what this channel is about
now I know Jill obviously because she's
in mov makers and I've I've learned
about her business but I'm coming
through the lens of I've never heard of
you before and this is what you want to
assume when people are coming to your
channel they have never heard of you
before you are not making videos for
your mom you're making videos for people
who have no idea who you are it's your
first time being exposed to your brain
and so we want to show them what we're
about so I don't know what she's about
from this Banner from the avatar from
the name I don't know what she does if I
go back to here he does investor
financing now I would put his name
somewhere here right I don't he went
maybe too far in the opposite direction
he's like this guy's name is B it
doesn't say that anywhere right but it's
talking about investor financing we look
at Dan Dan's tell tell me about how to
do wise money tools he's a financial
expert a speaker author investor
business owner right he helps people uh
discover how to build their wealth
exponentially right so I get a sense of
who Dan is and what he's about when I
come to Jill's page I don't know what
she's about yet and so what what that
means is you're requiring the user to go
do extra work and so we don't want to
have to make them do extra work we want
them to instantly understand what it is
that we do so that's the first start the
the banner can do some heavy lifting to
explain what we're
about uh the the next is then when we go
to the the channel homepage she doesn't
have any playlist set up so this is
another way for me to be able to
understand what am I going to get when I
come to your channel and so she's got
this video series and so how to build a
personal brand ladies don't settle how
to meet the right man how to find and
keep real love how to manifest what you
really want how to overcome your
self-doubt secret success and happiness
it feels like it's all over the place
now these two are are kind of a greenish
color and seems to be about love and the
yellow ones seem to be more about
personal devel velopment or growth but
ideally what you can do is set up
different playlists on your Channel
people don't consume my playlists but
it's set up as a marketing brochure when
I come here all I see is this one
playlist where if we go back let's see
what these guys have done here we've
got we've got popular videos we've got
SBA lending short-term rental cpce
financing multif family financing shorts
so I get a sense of what this guy's all
about right it's the investor financing
podcast and he's going to teach me about
SBA lending and short-term rentals and
all these other things right so he has
content that speaks to what he's all
about so I'm not going to expect love
and romance uh information from this
channel I'm probably not going to get
personal development stuff from this
channel right it's very clear what he's
all about so when I come here there's
just not as much Clarity and when
there's not much Clarity it creates
confusion when there's confusion people
don't understand what your brain is all
about and so we want that to be a lot
easier so I would recommend thinking
about what do we want to show in the
banner here that explains what is that
we do this picture is beautiful you know
the font works the signatures there
awesome but who are we and then having
videos here different playlists that
speak to different series that we're
trying to create here as well and then
even this first sentence that we have in
our description this is on our about
page so if we go to the about it'll show
all of this description but most people
won't go that far so what does it say
here I want to take you on a journey to
live your best life it's called The
Summit life I guess experience so I
still am not clear on what this channel
is all about and what I'm going to get
and so we don't want to lose people so
the lesson for this one is make it clear
what you do okay next up is make content
that drives business so for the
entrepreneurs out there who are not just
trying to be influencers and not just
try to make money off of advertising but
you have a real business this is what we
love doing with Movie Makers too is we
have entrepreneurs who who have a
business who sell coaching who sell
products who sell programs and they want
to use a YouTube channel to help bu
revenue for their business not only
trying to make money off of AdSense so I
always ask people when I'm first
coaching them what do you sell what is
your business how can I help like if we
could drive targeted traffic to your
landing pages to your website from your
YouTube channel who are the people that
we want to have on and so we want to
show the process of the thing that we
sell so whatever it is that you sell
understand that there is an education
process people go to before somebody
hires you they're going to check out
your website they want to learn more
information so there's information that
you have to put in front of the actual
sale it's not just like buying a pack of
bubblegum uh that's an Impulse buy right
people are not buying Chuck's program
his coaching off of an Impulse they're
buying because they want to learn a
little bit more and say this is a guy
for me so if you have a complicated sale
or if you have an expensive sale you
have to put information in front of it
now the best way to be able to sell the
thing that you're selling is to show me
the process of you doing the thing and
so Chuck is a great example here where
he is doing a lot of these direct to
camera videos so he's got a great setup
again you know he's got his Banner he's
got his Avatar it's zoomed in I can see
his face Life 2.0 buildin version two of
yourself I get a sense of it's personal
development of what I'm going to learn
he's a Coach and he's got you know
various thumbnails he's he's the face of
everything he could have more consistent
design as well on here but he's in all
of them and they're a good you know
length 10minute plus and he's being
consistent two hours 4 days 5 days six
days so he's pretty pretty consistent on
his content but it's all solo content
it's all him going direct to camera it's
this one is here it looks like an
interview but the rest of them are all
him going direct to camera where what
does he sell so it's I'm always curious
think about it for your business what do
you sell because we want to use social
media to help you sell more of the thing
that you're trying to sell so if I hit
his homepage let's see what he sells
coaching for men the very first thing
that comes up is coaching for men what
will profit a man if he gains the whole
world but loses his soul so he's he's a
coach for men perfect you know what we
should have let's stay in touch I like
that picture you know what he should
have if he's a coach coaching content
what do you sell Chuck sells coaching
then what should we have on here is
coaching content I want to see Chuck
coaching somebody I want to see him
coaching a man through a problem that
they're facing because you can make a
video like this about how to change your
mindset and how to master your mindset
that's great nothing wrong with that go
and do it have have an 11 minute video
talking about how to change your mindset
awesome what's even more powerful if
you're a good coach is show me you
coaching somebody have somebody come on
who needs to change their mindset and
you help them one on-one now there's a
couple questions a couple of push back
that I always get when I recommend this
uh the first is nobody's gonna want to
come on my show you know I'm talking
about very sensitive things very private
things not everybody needs to come on
your show you just need a few right if
he's doing a weekly show you just need
50 people a year to come on your show
and the people will go on Jerry Springer
and Dr Phil and share the things that
they share they will come on your show
where you're actually trying to help
them right you're not trying to have a
gotcha moment you're not trying to have
a make you look bad moment you're trying
to help them and the way that you
present it is working with Chuck is
expensive like working with him is going
to cost whatever it's going to cost I
don't know if he has his pricing on here
doesn't look like it but working with
Chuck is going to be expensive cool some
people can afford that some people can't
if you can't afford that then he does it
for free and this is what you can do if
he has an email list if he has people
who follow him on social media we can
look at as an example if you're trying
to get people onto your list go to your
Instagram how many people does he have
he's got 686 followers on his Instagram
amazing what you do is then you DM them
one by one in a video say hey hey I'm
starting a new show or who are his
followers let's see okay there's
me and I see you know a whole bunch of
other people there's there's Jill let's
go it's a family movement makers this is
great okay but we go down you know uh
and he he coaches men so hey hey Jay
Scott hey Mesa son hey uh Amato right
hey all these people like one by one you
say I'm starting a new show for my
YouTube channel coaching men normally I
charge blank but instead this is going
to be free for you but the but it's
going to be up on YouTube so other
people can learn from your story as well
and we're not we're not bait and
switching we're not promising some
private session that then is you know
surprise it's on you YouTube and
everybody can see it right they know in
advance that this is what they're going
to get and what it does is some people
will see that and say yeah I'd love the
chance to have somebody help me and if
it helps other people great I'm I'm
happy to come on and other people may be
like well I don't want it to be public
but can I hire you and that becomes the
model right if it's public then it's
free if it's private then it's paid and
so it's a chance to make content that
actually helps convert to your offer as
well as hopefully is more fun like if
Chuck has a great coach he'll probably
have more fun actually coaching somebody
than just making these thought
leadership videos where you're talking
direct to camera it's a lot more fun
it's also easier to go longer and by the
way it helps you with your conversions
and that on the landing page for Chuck's
coaching program here he is talking I'm
assuming you three minutes direct to
Camera Awesome you know you know what
make this you know what make this even
better let me see you coach because now
you're just talking but if he had
examples boom boom boom boom boom right
if he had 10 examples of him coaching
and I get to see the AHA the wow moment
that like Chuck you just changed my life
moment now I want to hire you I want to
hire you from me too so it helps create
content for the channel it helps you
create long content helps you make more
fun content for you because you're
coaching and you're helping it helps
drive more business results for you and
it helps drive more conversions on your
uh landing pages and websites to
actually get people into your program
now there's a big big big big big caveat
with coaching content and it does not
work for everybody here's the caveat you
have to be a good coach sounds obvious
but a lot of people are afraid of
getting exposed a lot of people are not
sure about what questions are going to
ask if you're a great coach you should
be able to answer any question related
to your industry right you're not going
to come on and ask Chuck about a cooking
recipe and maybe he's a great chef I
have no idea but you're going to come on
and ask him about fear of success or
guiding meditations or changing your
mindset or imposter syndrome or
impatience or whatever the thing is that
you're struggling with and if you're a
good coach you love it if you're a great
coach you love this the most you love
this the best this is your ideal zone of
Genius but if you're not a great coach
then you're afraid and then you get
exposed and you honestly probably even
shouldn't even be selling coaching
services in the first place uh but
that's the key element if you are a
great coach this is the best strategy
for you and if you suck as a coach well
don't do this and go learn how to get
better as a coach but that's strategy
number four is make content that drives
business okay and the fifth strategy is
have more of you content so this last
one we're gonna be looking at Mark Neely
he's in my Movie Makers program he's
also in The Mastermind he's an amazing
human being again you look at this he's
got this is branding down Mark Neely
helping you invest in yourself in real
estate top 1% mortgage broker on a
mission help people heal from trauma and
anxiety awesome he talks about mental
health mark Le show real estate
education Business Development Allin
podcast Etc so we're off to a great
start already if I look at his videos
though here's what we've got going on so
Mark is crushing what we call the bis
Dev show and again this is where you
have people on who you're genuinely
interested in building a relationship
with that then can lead to business
results for you so he's having these
people on he's doing this show this is
looks like it's in a you know in his
backyard he's got some microphon set up
and he's filming and he's making great
connections awesome
this is him being the interviewer and
that's great and you should be an
interviewer if you want to build
relationships and build connection with
people what's missing now though is we
need more Mark content so be careful
that when you start a new series you
don't forget about all your other Series
right that it's an evolution so the BISD
show is going up consistently five hours
five days 13 days two weeks so he's
doing a weekly show which is great
awesome that should be a weekly show but
what we need need to add back into a mix
is more Mark content we don't want
people to forget about who Mark Neely is
that he is a top 1% mortgage broker that
he's trying to help people heal from
trauma and anxiety and we need to see
him doing that whether that's thought
leadership content direct to camera
whether that's coaching content of him
actually helping somebody and he is
actually great at this so he's done some
videos this is the most recent one here
you know is it too late to buy a home
this is two months ago and this is him
talking direct to camera and he had
another one here but this is only a
minute long but in between it's it's all
of these shows uh and then here even
these are clips from other shows that
he's done and so he is great at going
direct to camera and he has a ton of
wisdom that he can share and he's done
some of these like like this where he's
this is more informal this is just kind
of turn the phone on yourself and go
film and share your thoughts on what the
Market's doing and he's done some of
these which are more structured and more
professional and you know fancier camera
compared to something like this that's
just kind of filmed on the go on the Fly
both of these can work but the key thing
is when you're introducing a new series
into the channel to not forget about the
other series that help get you there and
so he's doing some shorts looks like
these were kind of miscalculated of a
short uh but I think he's got some
popular shorts going on here right so
he's got some shorts and and it's him
you know making content but I want to
see the long form content so whether
it's going to
be formal camera setup fancy directed
camera like this or whether it's going
to be more informal take the phone out
put it on yourself and tell me about
what's going on in the market we need to
see more Mark content on the channel and
for your brand All of You Beautiful
viewers watching we need to see more of
your content as well and so whenever
you're introducing new series think
about it like this think of it as a
weekly series so if you're going to do a
coaching show that's a week weekly
series if you're going to do a solo
thought leadership show that's a weekly
series if you're going to do a react to
the news show that's a weekly series if
you're going to be doing a bizde show
interview show that's a weekly series
and if you can't go and do that many
right it's like oh my gosh now I'm
already at four or five videos a week
okay then make it a monthly Series where
you're releasing one video per week
right the key is to stay consistent on
the series that you want to stay on top
of now if you say I don't want to do any
more coaching series I don't like
coaching if Chuck says I'm not going to
sell coaching anymore great stop the
coaching Series right if there's it's a
series that no longer serves you stop
the series but what we often run into
the danger of is we get really excited
about a new show and then that's all we
do and so Mark is now building his brand
as a guy doing all these interviews
amazing but what about Mark right are
you are you g to be the next Larry King
or are you also going to be the guy
sharing your own message and so we need
to add one and one one and one and for
every new series we add in we need to
make sure we're St consistent on the
current series that helped get us there
as well so Mark is an amazing human he's
got a great message he's got a a giant
heart a beautiful soul and uh I'd love
to see more of that content come out on
his channel too so to recap the five
more advanced strategies are number one
go longer with your content number two
have a consistent thumbnail design
number three make it super clear what
you do number four make content that
drives business results and number five
have more of you to see even more
YouTube training check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when I started paying attention to
how to win on YouTube my channel grew
same thing with like the titling like I
loved sort of artc cryptic T you don't
have like movie titles you don't even
really know what they mean until you
watch the movie that's what I was doing